The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT Open Courseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
OK we're going to do problem 3
now on exam 2 from the fall
2009 class.
Let's talk a little bit about
what the problem concept is.
This is doping.
We're going to talk all about
doping semiconductors.
As we say chemistry, where
doping is legal.
So we're going to look at the
things we should probably know
before attempting the problem.
You want to review your
doping principles.
How does doping works.
What are the mechanisms, your
conduction mechanisms?
So why does the material
conduct?
What's actually happening?
Your donor and acceptor levels,
understanding which is which.
And your p versus your
n type doping.
What those mean.
So look at those real quick
and do the problem.
Let's go on.
I wrote down the information
that we're
given in the problem.
The problem part a asks us to
find specifically how much
gallium is needed to reach a
certain carrier concentration
in our germanium.
So we're doping gallium
into germanium.
We're given the fact that the
germanium band gap is 0.7
electron volts.
We know that we want to
achieve a carrier
concentration of 3.091 times
10 to the 17 carriers per
centimeter cubed.
And we're working with 1
kilogram of germanium.
So we need to achieve this
density or this carrier
concentration in one kilogram
of germanium.
I've drawn schematically-- now
remember the germanium
crystals are in 3-D so the bonds
don't actually look 90
degrees like this-- but I've
drawn just for visual a
germanium crystal.
So this is what a
pure germanium
crystal would look like.
I'm going to draw the band
structure for the pure
germanium crystal now as well.
When you see a problem that
gives you your band gap and it
tells you this is about doping,
the first thing you
want to do is just
get some points.
Put some stuff on the paper
that you know to be true.
So let's draw the
band structure.
I'm going to abbreviate
conduction band with cb and
valence band with vb.
So here's my conduction band,
here's my valence band.
We're told that this is here.
We know our band gap
energy is 0.7.
OK and I'm going to use
this blue to show
where electrons are.
This just shows that there's
electrons in the valence band
going all the way up to the
top of the valence band.
That's how the valence band
level is defined.
So this easy points.
You've got this on the paper,
we're good to go.
Now what we're talking
about is putting
gallium into germanium.
So let's do that.
Let's take out this germanium.
And let's put a gallium
in its place.
We'll put it in red.
OK so this isn't exactly
correct yet.
Germanium makes 4 bonds.
If you look at the periodic
table you'll see that it has 4
valence electrons
to make bonds.
But gallium does not.
Gallium only has 3.
So what that means is that one
of these bonds can't exist
like this anymore.
So the way I like to draw it,
is we still have an electron
from this germanium but we're
missing one for this gallium.
And this is what a hole
basically is,
schematically, in doping.
So we're going to write
this as hole plus.
And the reason it has a positive
charge associated
with it is because in our
neutral crystal with no
charges you having an
electron there.
And you've just removed an
electron and now it's
positively charged.
You have a positive charge in
this region of the crystal,
which corresponds to
a missing electron.
So we just created a hole.
We have a hole here and
then it's going to
result in what we call--
I'll use red again--
an acceptor level.
And remember this band diagram
is an analogy for, these are
the energy levels where your
electrons can exist. So we
have these energy levels and the
valence band and we've got
energy levels up in the
conduction band.
What's just happened is that
this dopant has created an
energy level slightly above
the valence band.
If you have a donor level from
a different type of doping--
which we'll talk about
in a second--
you'll create a level right
below the conduction bands.
So we've got some points.
We understand the system now.
It's just going well.
So let's try to do a.
So a, as I said before is asking
us to figure out the
actual amount.
We're looking for grams. This
is what we're looking for.
Grams of gallium.
That we need to put into a
kilogram of germanium to
create a carrier concentration
of 3.091 times 10 to the 17
carriers per centimeter cubed.
Not too bad of a problem.
This is basically just
stoichiometry.
Dimensional analysis.
Here's how I did it and many
people did it this way.
I start off.
times 10 to the 17.
And I always keep my units.
That's really important.
So we're going to write
this as carriers
per centimeter cubed.
Now we're also told in the
problem, we have the
additional information that the
temperature is high enough
that all of the sites
are ionized.
What that means is that--
let's take a look
at this band diagram--
we have electrons existing
in the valence
bands up to that level.
We've doped and now the
temperature's high enough that
these electrons can be excited,
one of them in this
case can be excited to this
level here, the acceptor
level, creating, of course, a
hole in the valence band.
That's what it means that
it can be fully ionized.
So basically every gallium
atom that we put into our
material creates a carrier.
And why do I say that?
Because conduction is either,
the movement of electrons in
the conduction bands, which
we don't have. Or it's the
movement of holes in the valence
band, which we now
have. So we're talking
about conduction.
And so for every gallium atom
we put in, we're creating an
acceptor level, which takes an
electron up, which creates
some conduction in
the valence band.
Now if we add lots and lots
of gallium atoms--
there's a lot more gallium
atoms in here--
we're going to actually see
many more of these levels
showing up.
And you're going to get what
almost looks like very thin
bands, an acceptor band or
acceptor level there.
So we start off like this.
And I went into that's
digression because now I'm
just going to say that
for every atom we
put in we get 1 carrier.
And then we're going to say--
I want to be sure I
get this right--
we have 6.02 times 10 to
the 23 atoms per mole.
That's right.
And then we have 1 mole.
And notice how I'm being very
careful about the dimensional
analysis here.
Because if you put something
in the wrong top or bottom
you're off by 46 powers.
So don't make that mistake.
We saw that a lot on the exam.
So we're good here.
Let's do our dimensional
analysis.
We start off, we're looking
for this particular
concentration carriers
per centimeter cubed.
We have 1 atom creates
1 carrier.
1 mole has this many atoms.
And one mole of-- we're
talking about in this case--
gallium.
I'll put Gallium here
to be clear.
1 mole of gallium has
this much mass.
And you're left with something
like this.
You're left with 3.58 times 10
to the negative 5 grams per
centimeter.
Grams gallium per centimeter
cubed.
So we're looking good.
We're pretty close to the answer
but we don't actually
have the answer yet.
Remember we're looking for
total grams of gallium.
Not how many grams per
centimeter cubed.
That's pretty easy because
we're told the we have 1
kilogram of germanium and we
know the density of germanium
from our periodic table.
So looking at our periodic
table we can look up
germanium's density and we can
then back out how many
centimeters cubed of germanium
we have. We'll
do that right here.
So 1 kilogram of germanium
is 1,000 grams, times--
we have the density, which is
going to be times 1 over the
density, rather--
grams per centimeter cubed.
And that's going to give us
187 centimeters cubed.
And now we're good.
Because we know here we have
3.58 times 10 to the negative
5 grams of gallium per
centimeter cubed of germanium.
We have this many centimeters
cubed of germanium.
Multiply them together and you
get the answer, which is 6.69
times 10 to the negative
3 grams of gallium.
So that's part a.
Just dimensional analysis
and stoichiometry.
But I stress, be careful about
the way these things are.
Even I pause to make sure
they're correct because if you
get this wrong, the whole
problem's wrong.
You're off orders of 46.
You're off by orders of 1,000
here, so just be careful.
Part b.
We've actually already answered
when we drew it up,
we threw down the
things we knew.
We knew that we were
creating a hole.
And a hole corresponds
to p type doping.
How do I remember p and n?
It's easy. p means positive.
We've created a hole, which
has a positive charge.
n, I think of as negative.
So if you had put something else
in there like arsenic,
arsenic would've had an extra
electron compared to
germanium, which means you
have a negative charge.
So n negative.
So we have p type doping.
We're done with part b.
Easy.
Part c.
I'm just going to erase some of
this stuff here and we're
going to draw a couple more
of these band diagrams. So
basically what we're asked to do
now is to think about, what
does this band diagram look
like at different
temperatures?
Because it actually looks
slightly different.
I've drawn it here
schematically.
But let's actually think
about what it looks
like in real life.
So let's do 2 more of these.
And we'll use that one
as well for part c.
OK so I'm drawing my
conduction bands.
These are my conduction bands.
These are my valence bands.
I have the same band gap
for all of them.
So you know band gap here,
here's the band gap.
It's always worth
putting down.
If you know it's true,
put it down.
And we know that
in both cases--
let me just get rid of this
thing here; we're going to
start from the beginning;
put our electron back--
we've created all these
acceptor levels.
Because we've doped with more
than one gallium atom.
We have many, many, 10 to the 17
gallium atoms. Which sounds
like a lot, but in a mole we
have 10 to the 23 spots in a
mole of material.
So it's 6 orders of
magnitude less.
So we have these systems and
we're asked to do them at--
I'm going to keep going
back and forth--
300 k, 4.2 k and 1200 k.
That's Kelvin.
Let's go with the extremes
first. And we'll do the middle
one, 300 k, once we have an
idea of what's happening.
So basically, in the very
beginning when we to dope in a
material, time t equals 0 and no
electrons have had a chance
to move around.
You have all your electrons in
the valence band, you have
these open holes in your
acceptor levels.
And the reason that electrons
would move between levels is
if they have some energy
associated with them.
Now why would something have
energy in a crystal?
Well that's because of
thermal vibrations.
It's a thermal energy they have.
So it's completely based
on the temperature at which
the crystal exists.
So at a very low temperature--
let me write that up
there for you, this
is our basic equation--
at a very low temperature we
have a very low thermal
energy. kBT: this is the
Boltzman's Constant.
At a very high temperature, we
have a very high thermal
energy, which means that these
electrons have the ability to
move between levels
more easily.
So here's our very
low temperature.
At a very low temperature
we can actually
calculate the energy.
We'll find that the energy
here is about--
just so you have a scale--
it's about 0.00036
electron volts.
Now you say to yourself, wow
that is a lot less than 0.7
electron volts, which is
the energy of this gap.
So there's no way these
electrons here can even make
it up to this acceptor level.
That's not exactly true.
This is best thought of as an
average thermal energy that an
electron will have. It's
based off of a
distribution, if you will.
So most electrons will have
around this energy.
But some will have a little bit
more and some will have a
little bit less.
And very, very, very few at the
tail of that distribution
will have enough energy to
actually make it up to one of
these levels.
So the way to do this problem,
to be actually fully correct,
is to say that and explain it.
I actually, when I did this
problem on the answer key, I
have an electron, one electron
going up into one of these
spots and the rest
are all empty.
I denote that with a little
bit of blue here.
But everything else is empty.
We've got a hole here.
So there is a finite, very
small, amount of conduction.
But it's extremely small.
And it's extremely unlikely to
have electrons moving around
but probabilistically
it will happen.
That's 4.2 Kelvin.
Very, very low.
Let's go to very, very high.
Starting at the beginning again,
we know all of our
electrons are in the
valence bands.
At 1,200 we have an energy
of about 0.1 eV.
Still less than 0.7.
We have a significantly larger
proportion electrons in that
distribution, which
are at 0.7.
So we actually do have electrons
that will move up
into the spots.
And even many that'll move
up here as well.
Because they can overcome
this 0.7 eV.
So we've got some electrons,
they're going to move here,
they're going to fill
up most of these.
Because this delta here, the
difference between our
acceptor level and our valence
band, is actually quite small.
It's extremely small.
That's another reason why
we have an electron
moving up at 4.2.
I should have mentioned that.
This is very small.
This gets pretty much
completely filled.
And I'll denote that with
a blue line here.
And we have some electrons,
even going up into here.
What that means, that that has
to correspond to electrons
being depleted out of
the valence band.
This is the way you would
draw this picture.
So we lose these electrons
from the valence band.
Some jump up to the acceptor
levels and the rest will go up
to the conduction band.
So this is 1,200.
We have more than enough energy
to reach this acceptor
level and we have
probabilistically some
electrons will make it up
to the conduction bands.
That's the best way
to think about it.
Now let's go back to our
middle temperature.
I think the best way to do
this one is to just go
somewhere in the middle.
That's the safest play, right?
So we're at a temperature
which corresponds
to about 0.025 eV.
Now that is obviously smaller
than the gap.
Probabilistically we'll still
get some electrons in the gap.
Diminishingly small.
But we'll put one up there.
OK maybe one goes up there.
And it's still much bigger than
the delta here between
the acceptor level and
the valence band top.
So these electrons will still
pretty easily make their way
into the acceptor level.
Now I'll put a little
bit here.
We're going to lose electrons
very slightly.
That's how I would have
done that problem.
It sort of looks like that
on the answer key.
Now I want to emphasize that,
what is what's the
importance of this?
Well when you dope, you're
creating conduction.
Why is that?
Because the more we dope, the
more holes we have that can be
played around with.
So we have more and more
of these acceptor
level energy levels.
And what happens is these
electrons at finite
temperatures--
temperatures above 0 Kelvin--
will move into those levels.
And they will cause conduction
in the valence band.
And you know at high
temperatures, back over here,
we have electrons moving to the
conduction band, which is
traditionally what we think of
when we think of conduction,
electrons moving around.
So we have in this case
conduction in the conductor
band as well as in
the valence band.
So that's this problem.
This problem was generally
pretty easy; many
students got it right.
The learning goals and
objectives we had from this
problem were, number 1, to
understand doping principles.
What it means to n
and p type dope.
Holes versus electrons
and how you get them.
So if you have germanium or
silicon, those are very common
examples and you dope
things into them.
So gallium or arsenic or
aluminum, for example.
We talked about conduction
mechanisms--
just like here--
and we also talked about the
donor and acceptor levels.
So the donor levels are just
slightly below the conduction
band and are full
of electrons.
And the acceptor levels are
just slightly above the
valence band and initially
holes.
So that's probablem 3 and I hope
you had good luck at It.